and joining us now is ben crump the
attorney representing brianna taylor's
family
good morning mr crump you said a week
ago that at a minimum the three officers
should be charged with second-degree
manslaughter
what do you make of the kentucky
attorney general's explanation
as to why none of them were charged
with briana taylor's day brianna
taylor's family as
do me and my co-counselors lanita bacon
and sam aguiar
we think it's just outrageous it's
offensive
uh we're still trying to figure out
what evidence did kentucky attorney
general
daniel cameron present to that grand
jury did he present
any evidence on behalf of brianna taylor
because if he didn't he unilaterally
decided
that he was going to exonerate these
police officers
and that brianna would never get due
process
that she would never get justice and so
we are demanding
that he release that transcript so we
can see if there was
any evidence that brianna have any voice
in that grand jury proceeding
he's the attorney general spoke to
brianna taylor's family yesterday did he
not what did he say
he spoke to them about 10 minutes before
everything was released to the public
and he did not go into the nuance
they were not told that the wanton
endangerment charges
were for the white neighbors apartment
and not for brianna's apartment
did not tell them that there were no
charges for the bullets going into
brianna's body
i did not tell them that uh the black
neighbors that had bullet go into their
apartment
did not have any wanton endangerment
charges so
it really underscores the fact that
there just seems to be two justice
systems in america
one for white america and one for black
america
and this was shown yet again in this
grave miscarriage of justice
just grave miscarriage of injustice you
know um
ben we talked to kenneth walker's
attorney in the last hour and he told us
that
he feels it's a cover-up would you use
that phrase too
well i think it was a sham proceeding
and that's why we're demanding
gail that these gran this grand jury
transcript
is released so people can see
if anybody spoke for brianna in that
grand jury proceeding
because black women lives matter and
brianna taylor life
matters the fact that not just black
people but
if you are a parent of a daughter
a parent of a child you should
be troubled by this because tamika
palmer's daughter
brianna taylor was killed in the
sanctity of her
own home and our legal system our
criminal justice system
is trying to say it's justified it's
okay and you know just because they say
it's legal girl
that don't make it right we know
throughout history
they have said things are legal but that
don't make it right
yeah and that's what i keep thinking i
keep thinking about the family today ben
and how they're processing their grief
while they are still calling for peace
it's not okay the two louisville police
officers were shot in the streets
luckily they're going to be okay but how
is the family processing their grief
they're awarded 12 million dollars so on
some level somebody thought that some
wrong
that they had been wronged in this
particular case to have
no charges nobody held accountable for
the death of their daughter
you know gary king that that is the hard
thing the civil settlement was very
significant
on many fronts it set a precedence for
systematic reform and speaking to the
value of black women's lives
in society however as tamika palmer says
she wanted accountability
these officers to be held accountable so
it would serve as a deterrent
so we can prevent future brianna taylors
she
is trying to define the legacy of her
daughter
in the chaos of all of this and she
really wants that legacy to be
to prevent these unjustifiable killings
of people of color
with nobody being held accountable ben
yesterday the
attorney general for the first time said
that they had a witness
who claimed that the police announced
themselves before they went in we had
not heard that before had you heard that
before
we had heard that before but i want to
put this
in proper perspective uh our legal team
have
12 witnesses 12 neighbors that say they
did not hear the police knocking
announced
and this alleged witness that they keep
presenting he apparently gave
two previous interviews where
he said he didn't hear the police
knocking announced
so if daniel cameron only presented his
perspective
and then present the other 12 neighbors
then
he has unilaterally made a decision
on whether or not brianna would ever get
due process whether she would ever get
justice
and that is not right yeah kenneth
walker's attorney made that same point
that this witness has apparently changed
her story and it's called a no knock
warrant for a reason
because the reasoning is that you don't
announce yourself and all the
several witnesses who were there that
night including kenneth walker when you
hear him on that 9-1-1 tape
after it happened he said he had no idea
who these people were
who came into his department he thought
he was acting in self-defense to save
himself and brianna taylor it's
there are still many many questions on
this case and i know that
you are still working very hard thank
you ben crump for joining us this
morning
we really appreciate your time